let's do another example of using a
virtual compass in virtual straight edge
to draw a tangent line to a circle and
now we're told to construct a line going
through P tangent to the circle and in
this example P doesn't sit on this
circle P is outside of the circle so we
want to draw something like and actually
let me get my let me get my straightedge
out so so my straight edge and I have my
controls up here this is on the Khan
Academy exercise constructing a line
tangent to a circle so I have that up
there so let me add a straightedge once
again you know you could try to eyeball
it and we're gonna go through P you want
to be tangent to the circle so hey yeah
maybe something like that that looks
pretty good but like we've said in the
other in other geometric constructions
videos that's just eyeballing it we
don't know how precise that actually is
so what if we had a compass in a
straightedge how do we make something
more precise and actually in the process
of doing it we'll make really fun
patterns so how do we do that well what
I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna try to construct a circle that is
that has the segment PC as a diameter as
a diameter so let me draw that so I want
to construct a circle that has segments
PC as a diameter as a diameter and in
order to do that I need to figure out
where the center of that circle is and
you'll see in a second why it's useful
to have this circle that has PC as a
diameter so where is the center it looks
like it's roughly here but how do we
actually construct it to do that we're
going to figure out the midpoint of
segment PC or CP and to do that what I'm
going to do is construct two circles
I'll just make them a little bit larger
so one centered at C one centered at C
make it reasonably large maybe that big
and then I'm going to construct another
circle of the same radius of the same
radius as that large one that I just
constructed so it's that same radius but
I'm not going to Center it at P I'm now
going to Center it at P now why is why
is this interesting why is what I just
did interest
well where these two larger circles
intersect are going to be equidistant to
P and C how do we know that well all the
points on this circle are equidistant to
see all the points on this circle are
equidistant to P and these circles have
the same radius and at this point right
over here they are equidistant to both
of them because it's it's on both
circles so this point is equidistant to
both of them and so is this point right
over here and so they both sit on the
perpendicular bisector of this segment
of the segment CP so actually let me
draw that so if I draw a line that looks
something like this this right over here
is a perpendicular bisector of of line
of segment CP now what we really just
care about is that it is bisecting it
because we wanted to find the midpoint
and now that we have found the midpoint
of our segment we're ready to construct
that circle I talked I talked about a
circle centered at the midpoint centered
at the midpoint and it has a diameter it
has CP as a diameter so I got that far
but why did I go through all of this
trouble to do that well now we're going
to use the idea that if you have a
triangle embedded in a circle where one
side of the triangle is a diameter then
you're going to have a right triangle
what am i talking about well let me
actually just draw the triangle so let
me add a straight edge here so I'm gonna
draw a triangle so it has one side as a
diameter so we're gonna we're gonna
embed it in this circle that I just
constructed the circle centered at this
midpoint this circle right over here CP
is clearly a diameter and I'm gonna
embed it in CP but I'm gonna put it at
this point right over here because this
point sits on this circle centered at C
and I'm gonna draw another line so this
other line let me put that there and
this there so my claim is that this is a
right triangle how do I make this claim
and I've proved it in other videos is
it's embedded in a circle it's embedded
in this circle right over here that's
highlighted in yellow it has a diameter
and has a diameter for one of its sides
and that side is actually its hypotenuse
so and we proved it in other
so this is a right this is a right
triangle well why is this useful for
proving or why is this useful for
constructing a tangent line to this
circle over here to circle the circle
centered at C well this side right over
here that I have an orange that I have
I'm highlighting right now that's a
radius of C and if that forms a right
angle with this line right over here
then they must be then this line right
over here must be tangent and to really
make it look tangent I'll elongate it a
little bit just like that and there you
go if you feel good that this looks like
it's truly intersecting at a right angle
and that this segment that I'm
highlighting in orange right now is
truly tangent so once again a lot more
trouble than just eyeballing it and
trying to draw it and actually a lot of
y'all probably could have eyeballed this
segment right over here but if you're
doing something on a larger scale you
want to be more precise it's useful to
be able to do these constructions and
frankly while you're in the process here
while you're dealing with the compass
End and the ruler or the straight ahead
you get a new appreciation for what
these tools can do and you're also
making some pretty pretty fun patterns
and designs I almost feel like hanging
this one up on my on my wall